hi i'm walter deyoung the potato breeder
at cornell
i've been here for about 21 years this
is my 21st or 22nd
crop season i'm currently standing in
the middle of what we call our raised
beds where we plant our first generation
seedlings about 20 000 or so each year
we end up harvesting four tubers from
each pot and those go into the field
next year for
additional generations of selection
my breeding program has two main foci
the first is to develop varieties that
are resistant to the golden cyst
nematode and the second is to develop
potatoes that have a quality that people
want to grow them for us it's largely a
focus on chipping potatoes
golden nematode is a serious quarantine
pest that's present in new york and no
other states
and for about 40 years the strategy in
new york for controlling gold nematode
has been to require growers to grow
resistant varieties as part of an
improved crop rotation
of course if we're going to mandate that
growers grow resistant varieties someone
has to develop them
my predecessor started that and i've
been continuing it since i've been here
so um
we've been quite successful in terms of
controlling gold nematode with resistant
varieties there hasn't been any
meaningful spread in new york
for the past 30 or 40 years
cis nematodes are kind of an attractive
pest to control by resistance this isn't
something you could do with a lot of
other pathogens because resistance is
even if it evolves in a field doesn't
spread
very quickly
that said
some of our varieties have become so
popular the growers want to grow them
year after year after year on infested
land and a new race of gold nematode has
arisen
and for the past 25 years or so we've
also been breeding for resistance to a
new strain
just a couple of years ago we released
our first varieties resistant to that
new race
varieties brody and upstate abundance
when it comes to quality the primary
traits we focus on in our program are
breeding
new varieties of chipping potatoes
potato chips were invented in new york
um so for nothing else for historical
reasons our program has long focused on
developing new varieties for potato
chips
key attributes in a chipping variety
around tuber shape relatively high
starch content so the potatoes don't
absorb much oil
and
low accumulation of
sugars particularly glucose and fructose
during cold storage because that leads
to a my yard reaction and browning when
the potatoes are fried
we've been quite successful in
developing
good chipping varieties the most widely
grown chipping variety in the country
today is lamocha a variety we released
10 years ago
that and a couple other varieties we've
released collectively represent about a
quarter of the chipping potatoes
that are grown in the us today
the biggest challenge in potato breeding
in my view
is the extensive segregation that
happens after we make any cross potato
is incredibly heterozygous it has a snip
every 15 to 20 nucleotides
potatoes also ought to tetraploid so as
a result every time you make a cross
literally thousands of loci are
segregating the potato seedlings behind
me may look cute and innocent what they
really reflect is an incredible amount
of genetic chaos
um
at the moment
going forward
the potato breeding and genetics
community has a lot of different options
and it isn't clear which one is going to
be best suited to dealing with the huge
amount of variation that we have
for the time being i think all of us
have to continue breeding at the
tetraploid level
i'll be starting to use genomic
selection soon to make it more efficient
for how we select for processing traits
in our program and
for no other reason i got to keep
developing gold nematode resistant
varieties that new york growers need
there's a several large companies as
well as a large public sector effort in
the u.s to reinvent potato as a diploid
crop a diploid inbreeding tolerant crop
that will clearly simplify how much
segregation we deal with whenever we
make
make a cross
it isn't clear to me
how long it's going to take until we can
reduce the pretty sizable genetic load
the potato has so that diploid potatoes
can yield as well as tetraploids at the
moment the best diploid potatoes yield
about 70 of the best tetraploids
my best guess would be a decade or more
um
on a global scale it's clearly the most
reinventing potatoes of diploid is the
most important experiment that's going
on in potato breeding and genetics
around the world but it's it's it's a
long-term experiment
i'm contributing to the us effort by
extracting diploids from some of our
better tetraploids as we create a
nationally diverse
broad set of diploid germplasm that can
be a foundation for the nation's diploid
breeding um going forward um and the
last area which i personally think in
the long term is going to have the
biggest impact on potatoes is skipping
meiosis and
recombination entirely and just using
gene editing techniques to
alter potatoes that we currently have to
make them better in specific and
designed and desirable ways so
gene editing isn't yet at a level as we
all know that's particularly um can be
particularly targeted to change any
given nucleotide to any other given
nucleotide as a former virologist who
was doing this 30 years ago it's
something i've always wanted to do in
potato and i expect when that becomes
routine
in potato the preferred way to improve
to do most the improvement we do in
potato is to take potatoes that have a
lot of attributes that we already want
and add individual genes or not
change existing alleles undesirable ones
to desirable ones to get the end product
that we want
and towards that end um in terms of
basic research my lab
already over a decade ago
isolated various
genes and potatoes that are
controlled potato color traits yellow or
tuber flesh or purple or red tuber flesh
purple red skin color
i guess the big picture is in potato at
the moment even if we could genetically
edit any allele we wanted to to any
other desirable allele we wanted we
don't know enough about the genotype
phenotype map in potato to have a lot of
targets edit today i think an awful lot
of work is still needed to make those
connections identifying genes that
control specific traits that's largely
what my own lab program is aimed at
i've recently shifted away from working
on color genes to trying to isolate a
bunch of disease resistance genes that i
care about nematode resistance genes uh
unsurprisingly given the importance in
new york to keep the gold nematode under
control and also
resistance genes to potato virus y which
has become an increasingly important
problem in the country potato virus y
has for a long time just been something
that reduces yield a little bit but
there are now necrotic strains that in
some varieties make the tubers
unmarketable that's a lot more of a
serious issue there are genes that we
have deployed in varieties that
haven't broken down for decades but
identifying those genes so that we can
edit potatoes to make them pvy resistant
or add it to agrobacterium or other
engineering means would further simplify
how we develop varieties going forward
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu